this is a production of cornell
university
thanks johannes
so thank you everyone for coming here
today um as johanna said this is what
i've done for the past i guess maybe
four years out of the past six years
that i've been here and um
and
it's basically uh looking at the
influences or impacts of applications of
bio even though coming through
humans originally black carbon and
landscapes and again this is in western
kenya mostly
so just as an introduction i want to to
just frame some of the nomenclature here
because i do skip around a little bit
depending upon the application so
pyrogenic carbon this is carbon that has
been derived from the process of
pyrolysis
and um and this is more of an
overarching uh
name for a bunch of different types of
then of pyrogenic carbon and so within
pyrogenetic carbon i'm defining things
based upon their intentionality so then
biochar is pyrogenic carbon that was
intentionally manufactured for
agricultural purposes
and then charcoal then of course is
pyrogenic carbon that has been
intentionally manufactured as a solid
fuel
and then you'll see often pyrogenic
carbon is also used with as black carbon
in some of the literature but in this
case we want to differentiate maybe some
of the soots and aerosols that are often
encapsulated within
black carbon
and remove those and so pyrogenic carbon
is basically those minus the the slips
and aerosols
so as part of the other introduction so
we've seen there they've been quite a
lot of publications and and
instances of applications or pyrogenic
carbon influencing crop yields often
positively influencing crop yields so
this one comes from ever the really
famous sites down in brazil the terra
prata
this one here comes from us in in kenya
of course looking at beans and then
legumes
and then another one this is what i did
for my masters and a lot of you might
know
some of the work that has come out of
this department with the chrono sequence
project in western kenya also looking at
applications of biochar and impacts with
crop yields however
a lot of the mechanistic well before i
get to that point so
here's a nice graph looking at then
biochar publications over the past about
decade or so and so just for reference
my initial
coming into cornell was in 2008 so this
is about the annual publications in
biochar and over the past couple of
years it's really grown exponentially so
the knowledge is is being built rapidly
you know every year
but despite that there's there still
tends to be a lack of mechanistic
approaches to
biochar and pyrogenic work in the
published literature
so we have these large implant
influences in crop yields and in some
environmental uh impacts but we don't
really understand what's really
happening at mechanistically on the
risosphere and so one of the things that
i'm hoping to do with this presentation
is to look at the mechanistic responses
of biochar to biological nitrogen
fixation and then following that if we
get some positive responses what are the
implications for moving to intentionally
applying biochar or other pyrogenic
carbons at the larger scale across the
landscapes and so this is also something
that's really lacking from literature
and so we hope to
to tackle this also by looking at
movements of natural pyrogenic carbon
within the landscape
so moving into the first chapter uh here
we want to focus on
the the individual components within
biochar and then how that will affect
biological nitrogen fixation in tropical
soils
some of the impetus for this project was
that there's been one really nice paper
that came out a couple years ago looking
at the impacts between
biochar application and biological
nitrogen fixation however this really
this is the one of the only studies that
you can find in the literature looking
at this and then the mechanisms are are
not really known in this paper by rondon
they they
tend to tie it to nutrient application
or nutrients that were in the biochar in
the minerals and that maybe influenced
nitrogen fixation but it was really left
as a black box
and so
this is a nice graph that that
looks at the
different
biochemical and chemical constituents
within biochar
so
uh we we now
are more
aware that biochar isn't really a
specific
thing it's more of a continuum of
processes and products depending upon
one would be the relative proportions of
individual biomolecules in the
feedstocks and so here we have amorphous
hemicellulose crystalline cellulose and
amorphous lignin so this is in the
unprocessed feedstocks and then these
proportions are of course change
depending upon what kind of feedstock
we're talking about and then once we
pyrolyze them so the pyrolysis then
intensity so that basically the
temperature increasing here on the
x-axis when we move across the paralysis
intensity we get really a change in a
fundamental rearrangement of these
materials
and so if you look down here we have
on the top part this this white area is
the pore space
this gray area this small little gray
bar here then is ash content so this
would be minerals calcium magnesium
potassium silica etc
here this medium gray in the middle is
the volatile material and at the very
bottom is what's called pyrogenetic
carbon or fixed carbon
and this uh and these three things
change the proportions relatively
relative to each other change
as
temperatures increase and typically the
the limit for what we'd apply
intentionally to agricultural fields
would be around 300 degrees celsius and
towards the maximum would be around 600
degrees celsius and so these are what we
would typically think to be relatively
good chars or have biochars that would
have a positive impact in
in agricultural productivity
so we wanted to do then we wanted to see
how each of these
particular components of the biochar one
would affect
the biological lantern fixation and how
we could manipulate these depending upon
feedstock depending on
paralysis intensity
and also depending upon maybe some post
treatments
and so some of our hypotheses were that
one
the fertilization response from the ash
minerals going into the soil from the
biochar would only be partially
responsible for some of the increases in
biological nitrogen fixation our second
hypothesis was that the volatile
material of the biochar will stimulate
some of the responses in the rhizobium
so we did this in a greenhouse
experiment and this was conducted in
kenya
the soil that we used was
under long-term agricultural production
for over a hundred years it was an
ultasol with relatively no nutrient
content but the ph
was just slightly acidic at 6.1
we used a bean variety that came from
seat that was sensitive to
nutrient responses in the soils and it
was also had a
nitrogen a nodulating and
non-non-dulating iceland so we're able
to partition out the amounts and
quantify of
the biological nitrogen fixation
uh then in this case we used the native
rhizobium so we did not add an inoculant
we use whatever was in the soil and we
added biochar at the equivalent rate of
15 tons per hectare and then across all
of our treatments we added a basal
fertilizer phosphorus application of the
equivalent of one kilogram per hectare
to sort of eliminate maybe some of the
absolute deficiencies in phosphorus
so with our biochar feedstocks we chose
a variety of feedstocks that all came
from western kenya
a couple of them were woody materials so
these were eucalyptus seligna and
dilinux regia which are both trees in
addition to that we used tea twigs so
these are twigs the woody twigs that are
coming from the tea bush
we used rice halls sugarcane bagasse
maize dovers and mace cobs
and for pyrolysis intensities we use
low temperature and high temperature so
350 and 550 degrees celsius
and in addition to this we wanted to
manipulate the chars as they came out of
the kiln or maybe when they were in the
kiln and so we one of the ways we did
this was to not do anything at all so
just take it right out of the kiln and
use it in our experiment another one was
to use steam so we injected steam during
paralysis and this is the what's
commonly used the common method that's
used to manufacture
so this is a black carbons for
adsorption
and um
and so what we what this typically does
is it blows out the volatile material
also blows out some of the um
some of the volatile materials oh i'm
sorry so the steam this is used to make
activated carbons which is a subset of
course of black carbon
and then we used another one was acetone
so after the biochar was manufactured we
leached it with acetone to selectively
remove some of the volatile materials
and so the volatile materials typically
have a oily or
tarry consistency and so they tend to be
more soluble in
solvents such as acetone
and then finally we used hcl a dilute
hcl
to leach out and dissolve some of the
minerals that were held in in within the
ash components and then afterwards with
the hcl treatment we adjusted the ph
back to the original ph of this of the
biochar when it came out of the of the
kiln
and then within all the pots we added
water and maintained everything at field
capacity and then we harvested them
approximately six weeks after planting
so here are some of the first results so
this is biomass
on the bottom in this medium gray this
is shoot biomass and then in the light
gray in the middle is root biomass at
the very top is nodule biomass and we
found really
quite dramatic and significant increases
in all metrics of biomass with additions
of our biochars relative to their
controls
so here's moving also with biomass but
now we're looking at the
the post-pyrolysis treatments so with
results regarding biomass we do not find
any significant differences between any
of our post paralysis treatments
now this is different pyrolysis
temperatures we also did not find any
significant differences in biomass
with our post pyrolysis
temperatures or with our pyrolysis
temperatures
so this graph the series of graphs then
looks at the nitrogen fixation and also
nodulation so on this axis we have
number of nodules and then on this axis
we have nitrogen derived from fixation
as both a total percent a percentage of
total nitrogen
and absolute magnitude of milligrams
nitrogen fixed per plant
and in this case we saw really some
significant differences in nitrogen
fixation and nodulation
between all of our biochars and between
the biochars and our controls
in this case looking at post pyrolysis
treatments
we found some significant differences
wherever we added acetone we got a bump
up in nodulation and nitrogen fixation
this is also true
with our high temperature biochars so a
high temperature biochars gave us a
stronger significant response over our
lower temperature biochars
so then we're trying to correlate uh
what of the constituencies within the
biochar
resulted in these changes and we did
this by first looking at principle
component analysis um and then we well
actually before this we did a multiple
linear regression once we took the
significant uh
factors that were coming out of the
multiple linear regression we ran that
in a principal component analysis
and we found
that nodulation nodule biomass and
nitrogen derived from fixation were
principally correlated to foliar plant
phosphorus and plant phosphorus uptake
we also found that the phosphorus uptake
and foliar pe were not correlated to
biochar p
so that the plants were getting more
phosphorus but this phosphorus wasn't
really coming from the bioja
so we wanted to do a follow-up
experiment to see if we could tease out
some of these
complexities
and and so this is a series of tape
actually one table uh that we'll be
looking at and just wanted to walk you
through everything so on the top here we
have two of the biochars that we saw
previously uh these two were the ones
that had the highest and the lowest
nutrient contents and so these were
dilinux and eucalyptus biochars
and then below that we have our controls
and so we used
a no fertilizer control which we saw
before and this time we have a
fertilized control which the fertilizer
had phosphorus and potassium and also
had micronutrients that were equivalent
to the same rate that we found in the
highest biochar that we had which was
dionyx
and in addition to that we have our acid
treated biochars for the biochars that
had
low nutrient contents that were
leached out
and we had these at both a high native
ph and a low native ph and these are
also in
comparison to the same controls that we
found up here
and so on the top then of course we have
a number of nodules we have nitrogen
derived from fixation as we saw before
and in this case we found similar
responses so where we added the biochar
we got greater
greater nitrogen fixation and nodulation
over our controls
and in this case we measured mycorrhizal
root colonization
and with that we found that there were
significantly greater mycorrhizal root
colonization with added biochars over
both of our controls
and looking at the acidic versus basic
biochar we found that the acidic voucher
still had greater nitrogen derived from
fixation over our fertilized control
another follow-up that we did is we
wanted to look more closely at the
volatile materials and the influence of
the volatiles on the native rhizobium or
not native resolving but rhizobium and
so what we did is we took the volatile
extracts that we had from our
biochars the acetone soluble volatile
extracts
and then we
incorporated that into yeast manitol
auger growth plates and then we
dropped using a drop plate method we
added uh rhizobium cultured rhizobium
and then grew them in an incubation
experiment and what we found was that
the acetone extracts with the low
temperature biochars across the board
gives very poor responses uh with
residual growth so we got below the met
the detection limit for all of the low
temperature biochars
we found this also to be true with one
of the high temperature biochars so the
biochar manufactured
from macedo at the high temperature also
gives us a really poor response in
residual growth
but then when we looked at the acetone
soluble volatile extracts from the high
temperature biochars almost all of them
gave us no significant differences from
the controls so whether we added them or
that we didn't added them they were the
same the resident basically did not have
any
any um having a significant effect on
rhizobial growth both negative or
positive
but with two of the extracts so the ones
coming from dylanox and rice at the high
temperatures we actually found greater
residual growth than with the control so
that the additions of these resulted in
a boost in residual growth
so then conclusions relating to our our
first hypothesis
that was related to nutrients in the
biochar we found that the biochars the
nutrients in the biochar was important
so whenever we
leached out the nutrients from the
voucher using hcl we got a decrease in
our responses but this wasn't sufficient
um
when we had the acidic leeched biochars
these were still giving us a better
response
than the fertilized only control
and then again
we got greater phosphorus uptake was the
prime seems to be the primary driving
variable for what the responses that we
saw but this was not
correlated strongly to biochar
phosphorus
so what we were thinking is that there
was greater responses with the
mycorrhizae was then leading to greater
uh
greater looking of the an excavation of
the mycorrhizae in the soil for
phosphorus and that was then fuddling
into the plant
ph was also beneficial whenever we added
the acidic biochars we got a decrease
from the basic biochars but again this
wasn't sufficient so the acidic biochars
still gave us greater responses over
both of the controls
then finally our last hypothesis related
to volatile material so some of them
definitely were detrimental that we saw
some of them were neutral and then some
of them actually gave us a positive
so we're not quite sure at the moment
why that might be um it might be that
they're they're feeding off some of
these materials or maybe there's some
sort of um bioactive molecules in there
we're not really quite sure but we
do know that that volatile materials
can't all be treated the same that there
is really a variable and variation in
responses
okay so now we're switching gears we're
still looking at beans and nodulation
but in this case we're looking at the
influence of biochar to mediate against
drought stress with rhizobium in the
soil
so again our objectives were to look at
the
physical properties of biochar
to
increase then
water availability under induced drought
stress conditions and our hypotheses the
first hypothesis was that the porosity
of the biochar will provide refuge
for the microorganisms that this refuge
then we have a higher water potential
than in the surrounding soil
and our second hypothesis was that this
effect will be greater it will be
expressed more
under
sandier soils than in clayer soils
so we also did this in a greenhouse
experiment in kenya we used the same
soil that we used in the previous
experiment except in this case we added
another treatment where we had pure acid
washed quartz sand and then we did
sequential mixtures of the two
in this case we did not use the native
rhizobium we added
an inoculant so this was c899 which is a
variety of rzobium trapezium
and we use three different carriers so
first carry we used was raw bagasse
that came from sugarcane manufacturing
our second carrier was biochar that was
produced from the spaghost manufactured
at 550 degrees celsius
and then the third carrier was portions
of the soil that used as a control
carrier for the in inoculants
and then finally we used uh we designed
our inoculant so that the nucleus that
we added matched the mpn of the soils
that were trying not to
boost the total population of soil
rhizobium but rather just augment it
with using this carrier
and to our knowledge
ciat899 had not been used in the soil
had not been introduced into the soil
before us and then the idea was to use
c899 as a biomarker as a so that we
could
figure out how these effects were
working
so we introduced three water regimes so
the first water regime
was no water stress and in this regime
we incorporated the nocu into the soil
and then we watered the field capacity
and then we planted
the second
water stress was a little more intense
where we incorporated our inoculant we
watered it fuel capacity then we allowed
it to dry for eight weeks
then watered back to fuel capacity and
planted
then our third water stress was was our
greatest water stress where we
incorporated the inoculant water to fuel
capacity dried it for a week watered it
again to fuel capacity and then dried it
and then repeated this wetting and
drying cycle for eight weeks and then
finally we watered it again field
capacity and then we planted
so our initial results this is looking
at biomass
so shoot biomass that is
what we found is what we expected that
shoot biomass decreases as our sand
content increases so on the x-axis here
we have percent soil so 100 soil 100
sand or yeah so zero percent soil 100
sand
and this was true across all of our
water stresses we got some variable
responses with shoot biomass in regards
to the inocument carrier that we added
in no water stress in pure sand we found
a significant response with biochar
versus the other carriers and the rest
of the soils there was no significant
differences in the responses
in our light water stress the only
significant difference that we found was
a greater response in shoot biomass with
our control over the bagas and in the
biochar carriers then finally under our
most intense water stress
on the pure soil and then the 75 soil
treatments we found that the biochar was
the one that gave us the greatest
significant response with shoot biomass
now here we're looking at the same soils
but
and water treatments but but focusing on
nodulation
in this case we've got very different
responses
our bagasse gave us the most significant
and really across the board and across
almost all of the water treatments
greater nodulation versus everything
else either the control or the biochar
the only exception was
under no drought stress
in the pure sand treatment we found
significant
greater and significant differences in
nodulation in response to our biochar
amendment
here's nodule biomass nodule biomass
follows the same trends that we saw with
not with um
nodulation
uh bagas was giving us the greatest uh
significant positive responses except
for in that one soil the sand and the no
drought stress where we got greater
significant responses with the biochar
next what we wanted to do is we wanted
to take the nodules and look inside of
them to see
what the occupancy was whether it was
indeed what we added under with 899 or
whether it was some of the native
strains and so we did dna fingerprinting
and one of the things that we found was
it was really quite difficult to get
any culturable
organisms from these nodules but when we
did get them we found that there really
wasn't any significant differences in
the proportions of eight nine nine
versus the natives with either our
bragas or our biochar treatments
and what we did find was that the actual
proportions were getting were relatively
low so zero to fourteen percent of the
nodules were the ones that we added with
eight nine nine
uh with the biochar with the vegas ten
to twenty three percent of the nodules
were or eight nine nine
so what we take from this uh
these these tables here are that the
nodules are really dominated by the
natives and not dominated by uh by our
introduced strains
so in conclusion uh
the biochar and porosity we did not find
this to be true
um the
gas was giving us the greatest
significant changes in rhizobium
uh with
really irrespective of most of our water
treatments
one of the reasons that we're thinking
for this is that we didn't find really
significant differences in the in our
significant numbers of in
introduced strains so the 899 that we
added to the soil so what's most likely
happening here is the gases is is
adding a boost to the native strains of
rhizobium rather than
maintaining the introduced strains
through the drought stress and so some
of the literature that we've been
pulling up was relating
what happens if you added some sugars so
simple sugars
excuse me to the soil you get a boost in
the native strains of our zobium
the bagas being a byproduct of sugarcane
processing industry it has relatively
high residual sugars and so most likely
what we're thinking is that the
residuals these residual sugars are the
ones that are responsing
that are causing the response in the
native rhizobium into the soil
and then finally what about the the
differences the significant differences
in the biochar with the sandy soil and
so what might be seeing here is the
greater buffering capacity of biochar we
do not find any significant differences
in the ph between the treatments
but that does not necessarily mean that
the biochar
wasn't able to to moderate the the
chemical conditions within the soil
there's been a lot of papers that showed
buffering capacity of biochar to be
really quite high and it seems like this
might be the most likely reasoning for
what we've been seeing
then finally with regards to the shoot
biomass i it seems like based upon our
previous study and looking at this study
that it might be linked to greater
nutrient uptake
or possibly nutrient allocation through
mycorrhizal
foraging so now we're switching gears
totally to the last chapter
and here we're looking at landscape
scale depositions and movement across a
black carbon or i'm sorry a pyrogenic
carbon across
landscapes at the small scale and also
landscapes at the larger scale
so there's been quite a couple of
studies that have documented
preferential loss of pyrogenic carbon
soil pyrogenic carbon in the literature
and these have both come from
agricultural landscapes which is rumple
and uh and her colleagues in 2006
and from natural landscapes and this was
guggenberger and his colleagues in 2008
in addition to that there's been some
evidence of large-scale mechanistic
coupling between pyrogenic carbon and
total organic carbon on the on the
landscapes and so here
jaffe looked at global rivers at the at
the exports of pyrogenic carbon and
total carbon from global rivers and they
found a really
strong and significant correlation
between the two however there's really
no process based linkages between what
people have been seeing at the smaller
landscapes in agriculture and the nature
and also at the global landscapes with
rivers
so we wanted to do is we wanted to
quantify both the magnitude and the
pathways of terrestrial black carbon
loss and and translocations within the
landscape
as
a response from initial fire event
we also wanted to
see if we can take a stab at identifying
the mechanisms for these movements
within the landscape so hypotheses was
one that erosion would be the dominant
pathway for terrestrial black carbon
loss in the landscape and that pyrogenic
carbon would we would be preferentially
eroded from the landscapes
so we did this by using um
some of the
the paired watershed studies that have
been established within this department
over the past couple of years
in western kenya and if you remember
john retcha this is what he did for his
entire phd
so we have here is a pair of forested
watersheds a pair of watersheds that
were converted into agriculture
relatively recently so 2001
a pair of watersheds that were converted
in the medium term so in the early 90s
and a pair of watersheds that were
converted from the native forest
in the 1950s
so we were
fortunate but also unfortunate for the
landscape to have
been able to monitor and evaluate the
initial
deposition of black carbon in the
forested landscape so in this early
early 2012 the local population
communities began the process of
clearing one of our forested watersheds
and then they used the woods the trees
once they were cleared
to create charcoal so what we saw
is is really the initial
the initial deposition what most likely
occurred over the past 60 years in these
soils
and this wasn't uh what was classically
defined as a slash and burn where the
entire landscape is cut down and burnt
rather it's a chop and char so that the
trees are chopped down
piled together and then paralyzed
to create charcoal for export in very
specific locations located throughout
the landscape
so here are some of the land use maps
that we created for these watersheds
again
on this panel we have the young
agricultural watersheds
medium agricultural watersheds and old
agricultural watersheds and one of the
things that i would like to point out is
that the land use change
does occur and does change between
the different conversion ages so we get
a predominance of maize cultivation here
and then as we move over time we get
more and more change into uh perennial
crops i know that i didn't include the
key but this green area is maze and
these this
this green spotted area are is uh tea
and also some wood lots that we have
here
so we took these landscapes and we we
divided them divided them into slope
units
so these are this would be summits and
then shoulders and
toe slopes
foot slopes foot slopes then toe slopes
and so we divided these across all the
landscapes and really use this for doing
some of our subsequent analysis
and so then within these different uh
katina landscape positions we found we
we
randomly located four different spots
across the landscapes than to sample for
soil and for other things
i want to put out that on
these sides so each of the watersheds we
have we established a weir which we took
both hydrological data and also water
samples from them
so across those those landscape
positions that i showed you we sampled
soil to two meters depth
we use the cornell sprinkle
infiltrometer to measure infiltration
and erosion rates we also captured an
erosion that we found for some
subsequent analysis
and then at the weirs we measured
bi-monthly stream
stream water concentrations in
pyrogenic carbon and also total organic
carbon
and in addition to that so that was the
smaller landscape across the larger
landscape
we measured
stream water concentrations of pyrogenic
carbon and total carbon
that were
in most of the major rivers that are
feeding into lake victoria so these are
included here in the green
for reference our smaller watersheds are
located up here in the red and we also
measured at the only outlet for the nile
of lake pretoria
there in jinja in uganda which is
highlighted in blue
so in these
rivers we sampled
randomly sampled five times
in one day though
water from the rivers and then we took
these the five
20 liter samples homogenized them and
took a one 20 liter subsample and we
acidified that for transportation
and then once we took the water samples
back to cornell we freeze dried them
and then we took the solids and analyzed
them along with our soils
on a subsample under high pi so this is
the hydrogen pyrolysis which is a really
good instrument that can get us
quantitative measurements for both
pyrogenic carbon
and total organic carbon
and in addition to that we took the rest
of the samples and measured pyrogenic
carbon and total organic carbon using
ftar and then used using the
partial least squares analysis we needed
a regression to make a predictive model
for black uh pyrogenic carbon and total
organic carbon for the rest of our
samples
so here are some of the results this is
uh with depth these are total organic
carbon and non-pyrogenic carbon and this
really follows what we would expect
in the surface we have really high
concentrations of these carbon species
and the concentrations decrease with
depth
now here we're looking at soil pyrogenic
carbon and then also the ratio of
pyrogenic carbon to total carbon
with
the total uh pyrogenic carbon what we're
finding is the same thing we saw before
actually this is up here
where we get our greatest concentrations
on the surface and we get a decrease
with depth
but unlike what we saw before
with the ratio of pyrogenic carbon to
total carbon we found an increase
in this ratio with depth so we're
getting enrichment in pyrogenic carbon
with depth in the soil
here we're also looking at soils except
we're looking at only surface soils and
now we're looking across the different
catchments so moving from the forest to
the old agricultural landscapes
and one of the things that we see here
is uh in the forest we're seeing really
kind of a random distribution
of total organic carbon and
non-pyrogenic carbon across the
landscape within the forested catchments
but with pyrogenic carbon as i mentioned
before we're really seeing very
site-specific increases in pyrogenic
carbon so these are the areas where the
charcoal was manufactured
as we move into the young agricultural
catchment with total organic carbon and
non-pyrogenic carbon we see an increase
in the concentrations and the total
amounts of these carbon species
along the topo sequence so we see a
decrease in the upper the upper
positions of the slopes and we see
an increase in the lower positions along
the foot slopes
this was not true with the ratio of
pyrogenic carbon to total carbon what
we're seeing is greater uh
concentrations of pyrogenic carbon
higher in the slope positions
when we move to the medium
conversions so these are the ones that
were converted in the 1990s
this uh all the significance moves all
this this interaction really disappears
and so we see
really a uniform distribution of these
carbon species across the the catchments
and then we move to the old conversions
the old catchments
we start to pick up then significant
changes and significant increases in
pyrogenic carbon here again we're seeing
concentrations of pyrogenic carbon
relative to
non-pyrogenetic carbon in the higher
slope positions across the landscape
this data is our our data that we got
from
the the sprinkle infiltrometer so
looking at erosion
and what we see
i want to draw your attention to again
the proportion of pyrogenic carbon to
total carbon we don't see any increase
any significant increase in this ratio
across any of our our sites
from the areas where we found really
high hydrogen carbon to the areas where
we found really low pyrogenic carbon
so this is giving us some evidence that
we are not finding preferential erosion
of pyrogenic carbon
so here we're looking at
pyro total
total carbon and pyrogenic carbon and
non-pyrogenic carbon exports
from stream waters from these catchments
and what we're finding here
is that
we get a really a
our greatest export is happening young
in the conversion process and then it
gets greater greater and greater and
then after which it goes back down again
as the carbon of course is lost across
the landscapes
but we're not finding any clear trend
with pyrogenic carbon so our proportions
of carbon isn't really changing very
much
apart from this one outlier isn't really
changing much across the landscape
i i would like to point out um that the
global average for all these is around
3.5 and so i'll be using that in the
next slide
so here we're looking at the same thing
so exports and concentrations of these
carbon species but then looking at the
larger landscapes so these large rivers
that flowing into lake victoria
and really the main point that i want to
show here is that the ratio than the
pyrogenic carbon to total carbon is
staying relatively constant with some uh
fluctuations but what we find is that
what we've the proportion that we found
in our headwater catchments are the same
proportion that we found in the coming
out of the yala river so the headwater
catchments were the headwaters of the
yala river so really we're seeing the
same ratio whether it's coming from a
small scale to a large scale of
pyrogenic carbon to total carbon coming
out
and so again i think this is greater
evidence that we're not finding
preferential erosion of pyrogenic carbon
into the landscape through rivers
at the small scale and also moving to
the large scale
and so in conclusion i think that the
evidence
is leading us to believe that
preferential erosion of pyrogenic carbon
is not seen across scales
and we might actually be seeing
preferential erosion of non-pyrogenic
carbon in the landscape contrary to what
was published in the literature
previously and we found that these
losses were greatest in the first 10
years after conversion after which
things tend to stabilize in the system
and finally this suggests that there's
low possibility of preferential losses
of intentionally applied biochar at
scale so if we were to think about
applying
uh biochar in agricultural systems at a
large scale across landscapes the the
really the the
the possibility of preferential erosion
of this applied biochar being a um a
potential large
monetary and time effort in getting out
there would be relatively low based upon
our data
so thank you very much i would like to
thank johannes and the rest of the
members of my committee and
my lab team for really being support of
really being a lot of support over the
past couple of years
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu
you